and um the government minister this
morning to raise coffee of course the
secretary of state for work and pensions
hello good morning it's lovely to see
you thanks for coming in um let's just
get sue great out of the way quickly
when will we get the report i don't know
um i'm conscious that the uh
sugre to um finalize her report uh you
will probably know quicker than i will
bouquet uh but it's important that uh
that be allowed to continue as indeed
the pm said about the police
investigation and it's being it's being
held up her end but we don't we don't
have a sense of why that is i really
don't know i know that uh
the government's committed to publishing
the full findings of the report uh and
that uh but the timing i actually have
no idea about okay did you ever go to
any parties at downing street
i'm not aware of any parties at downing
street but it's important that sue
gray's report is allowed to be published
in the pm uh sorry the police be allowed
to the investigation
i'm not aware of any parties i go to the
county street regularly things like
talking about jobs uh like discussing
things like the way to into work uh
campaign that we're launching today
we're gonna be talking about that in
more detail but did you ever go to any
parties at dining street have i ever
been to any parties in downing streets
the last party i recall going to town
street was the celebration of when the
uk left the european union following the
referendum and that was uh because boris
got brexit done and uh he will continue
to deliver yeah was there okay i don't
recall any cake the last cake i remember
is the one the sky news party with my
face on one of it i was literally
pictured eating my own face but there we
go so there's got to be a gag in there
somewhere hasn't that um you know we're
talking about bits of cake that he
potentially ate two years ago we're
being told that he wants to be more
statesmanlike and doesn't want to be uh
mem his memory to be of things like that
as far as the public is concerned yet he
intervenes airlifting animals out of
afghanistan what do you do that for
well the pm's been clear that he had no
individual decisions on all those
individual elements of operations you
know as ben wallace the defense
secretary has said it was a military
operation ben was in charge as defence
secretary
and i'm conscious that
absolutely people were absolutely
prioritized you know our brave armed
forces
worked really hard to get 15 000 british
nationals and afghans out of kabul in
that very difficult time and they're
being rewarded for that with medals in
uh as a part of operation but he's been
caught lying again because he said that
he didn't have anything to do with it
well the pm didn't make any individual
decisions about evacuations
what he said at the time here we go
yes please i've had absolutely no
influence on any a particular case nor
would that be uh right that's not that's
not how we do things in this country
well i think he said he had no
particular influence on individual yes
it's like nausea and sure tender fathing
look at this email then from the foreign
office official reading here we go
equivalent charity now said run by an
extra marine has received a lot of
publicity in the pm has just authorized
their staff and animals to be evacuated
well the pm has been clear in what he
said the defense secretary who was in
charge of the military operation has
been clear as well uh pm didn't ask him
to do anything like that you know i'll
be open with you there's quite a lot of
people will often claim the role of the
pm and supporting their stuff and
animals to be there a lot of people will
claim that the pm's involved in
supporting their particular pet projects
uh but the pm said he wasn't involved in
individual decisions that's what the
defense secretary he was in charge of
operation pitting overall has said as
well and i think it's important the
defense secretary uh is absolutely right
he prioritized people
and we were successful in getting
thousands of people out it was just
before the end of the evacuation of as
many people and animals as we could it
had to be authorized either by a cabinet
secretary or by the prime minister well
the defence sector all over it the
defense secretary um is clear that he
was in charge of the operation and the
pm did not ask him to do that also the
pm's i think spokesperson was saying he
was not involved in any individual
decisions
and i'm absolutely confident that ben
will have done the right thing in trying
to get as many people out of afghanistan
at that time as possible dominic dyer
who is a friend
of carrie johnson
said to lbc actually yesterday um that
the charity had lobbied all the
ministers about the charter flight as
well as the pm's wife
and and he had hoped that the pm's wife
would speak to the prime minister uh to
that end trudy harrison an mp and aid to
the pm trying to charter a flight on the
25th of august saying the boss wants
them to get out
well a lot of people will have been
lobbied i recall the extensive number of
emails i had as well at the time and i'm
conscious uh as i say the there was
i can't recall how many emails i
received but there was a lot of uh
concern at the time about what was
happening but the pm did not get
involved in the individual evacuation
decisions
and ben wallace are you sure because ben
wallace also was saying that as defense
secretary yesterday okay i there's
nobody more than me like is an animal
lover i absolutely love animals but i
would not prioritize animals over people
you are absolutely confident that the
prime minister didn't do that i'm
absolutely confident despite all the
evidence to the country well i'm the
evidence is clear also from the defense
secretary who's spoken on this at length
in the last i think 24 48 hours okay 183
people died in a suicide bomb attack um
those who had supported britain for 20
years were left behind only the pm and a
government minister could make things
happen towards the end
we had heard from the defense secretary
who had said that it was complete
bollocks using his um
terminology to try to get them out he
did not want to prioritize pets over
people
and then it all turned around dominic
dyer is saying he'd lobby the prime
minister's wife to make that happen well
i've no doubt a lot of lobbying happened
as i explained i
recall as an mp just like others will
have done will have had a lot of emails
uh but i will say that uh ben wallace
has been clear uh he was in charge of
operation pitting and the um and the pm
did not ask him to do any individual uh
kind of evacuations and the pm has said
that as well okay someone's lying aren't
they pm doesn't have a good track record
when it comes to lying he was sat twice
for lying and he's been uh caught um
telling porkys again over partygate but
you still prepare preferred or you want
my viewers to believe that he's not
lying and and the other evidence is
wrong
um i think uh i'm not just denying that
uh dominic dyer has said that people
lobbied ministers they did and then and
they are mps as well and the but i think
the situation is that uh you know the pm
is involved in a number of different uh
elements he trusts uh ben wallace to run
that successful evacuation uh strategy
under operation pitting and our armed
forces who were involved are going to be
uh rewarded with medals uh thanks to the
queen's permission for that but overall
you know there are a number of different
things the pm uh is doing really well
getting the big decisions on right the
success of the booster vaccine campaign
and that's why we're able to move
forward
today the first day stepping away from
plan b into plan a and i hope soon that
we will continue to learn to live with
covid and that's one of the reasons
we're stepping up
how we're helping people get into work
through our way to work program okay
let's go back to afghanistan and now
we've had the party political broadcast
we hear we heard that from the dispatch
box several times as well yesterday and
all of your colleagues have
recounted those facts to us uh
throughout the week 286 million pounds
had been allocated to afghanistan this
fiscal year um to try to help the people
there 145
million little over half has been given
so far why are we holding this money
back people are selling their kidneys so
they can eat
well that will be a decision on how the
foreign office will be allocating the
aspects of different funds we continue
through our foreign aid budget to also
spend a lot of money through
multi-lateral agencies
that has continued extensively
and we will continue to uh uh support uh
not only afghanistan but countries
around the world needing our help i mean
their kidneys cut out so that they can
get some money so they can eat
i i understand why it was a and
continues to be a difficult situation
for a lot of people
do remember that we've also extended
a settlement scheme for people to come
and live in this country
people have already arrived i know
through my own department we're trying
to help them get into work as well as
the other aspects as part of operation
warm welcome so i think that we are
doing a lot to try and help people who
understandably have enjoyed a very
difficult time when the taliban uh
looking at that do you think it's enough
well i'm conscious that around the world
that different uh countries will
continue to work together to try and do
what they can to help people in
afghanistan but ultimately we are doing
our bit with our
up to 20 000 people to come into this
country
and but that's already happened and is
separate to the scheme that was in place
for people who had helped in particular
the uk government during that time what
about what we're doing at home
inflation's running at a 30-year
high i think i'm right in saying
according to the uh joseph rountree
foundation 27 percent of children are
living in poverty 27 my goodness me um
should we scrap the national insurance
rise
well the national insurance rise has
already been voted through by parliament
and it's important way of making sure
initially we support the nhs but also
that longer term social care support
which we have committed to doing so i
think it's uh important to recognize i
think it's one in seven
of earners will be paying more than half
of the levy that will be generated
so the top 14 of earners will pay over
half of what will be collected through
that and actually six million people of
the lowest earners won't be paying
anything extra at all so there's a
number of ways that we're helping people
a household support fund
getting more people into works they'll
be better off financially uh helping
them and their families to make sure
that they can continue to have a better
life and also improve their mental
well-being too yeah more than a quarter
of kids
are living in poverty we're not doing
enough are we well there's a statistical
element that comes uh okay with um what
who defining who's in living in poverty
what's your connected poverty the
connection of poverty is in a
statistical term is about sixty percent
of median earnings compared to other
people i'm more focused on the material
deprivation aspect that's why we've also
put in place a half a billion pound
household support fund over winter to
particularly help but definitely the
best way to get out of poverty is for
people to be working and when a
household where both mum and dad or both
mum and mum or dad and dad are working
it's very unlikely that their children
will be in poverty and that's why i'm
focusing about getting
an extra half a million people on
twitter
i mean i work in a food bank on a friday
and i see a lot of people who come along
and they if they didn't come to that
food bank they wouldn't eat
i'm flagging that one of the best ways
is that they work as well some of them
have got two jobs and they still don't
earn enough money too well where you
have both parents working it's very
unlikely or it's something like three
percent uh chance of people being
poverty there's a number of things we're
doing in terms of the national living
wage will be going up from april uh also
we've already introduced something where
you keep more of your money while you're
still on in work benefits and those are
ways that we are trying to help families
as well and the best way that i can help
them is to try and make sure they get
into work okay and to that end you're
reducing benefits after people have been
looking for work from
12 weeks down to four weeks why are you
doing that that's not the case what
happens is that often when people are
especially new into
looking for work
our regime have been to
say you've got three months to find
something that's in your sector or
similar we know there's over a million
vacancies out there right now a lot of
them in key sectors so for new people
coming into the job center we can say
okay we're going to try and help you get
back into your chosen sector within a
month if you can't do it then then we're
saying to you it's important to get back
into work so we want you to take a job
of which you are capable because it's
always easier to get work once you're in
work and so going from any job to a
better job to a career process i'm
conscious that we still have well over a
million people looking for work a lot of
those have been doing that for over a
year now the longer you are out to work
the more difficult it can be to get back
so instead of the job of your choice
we're saying come on the experience you
will gain will be tremendous in helping
you get into work get more money in your
pocket
and not only delivering workers for the
economy
will be helping people with their
prosperity so the big change not only is
for people looking for work it's
actually about bringing employers back
into the job centres and really trying
to short-circuit the process of people
being connected being frankly a lot of
matchmaking going on uh so that we can
fill the critical
jobs people like the supply chain
warehousing are crying out for support
yeah but as well as the care sector as
well okay multiple sclerosis society
talking this morning saying it will
cause huge amounts of anxiety and stress
well in terms of um people with
different medical conditions may not
actually be being asked to look for work
and that's not part of this this is
about people who taxpayers are paying
week in week out to look for work what
we're trying to do is to accelerate the
process of getting people back into work
and filling the critical sector
vacancies which we know our economy
needs to do over a million vacancies out
there it's people can get work and we
will do be doing our bit uh to make sure
they get into a job okay
let me just go full circle before i let
you go prime minister yesterday at the
dispatch box said that it was right that
if a prime minister misled parliament
that he should step down um you agree
with that
i think what is fair to say let's just
said it well the prime minister said
what he said in this batch box it's
important to make sure that we continue
to wait for the appropriate
investigations to be underway and that's
exactly what we're doing well one of
them's completed they're arguing about
and and to that end um we've seen that
it has been given to the police our
prime minister likely to be investigated
by the police under caution my goodness
me well you know even more of the
details than i do okay on that but i do
know that pms said it's right that the
police should be allowed to investigate
you know they have operational
independence and that's appropriate to
do so you believe him on that but you
also believe in that when he says that
if he's misled parliament then he should
go
i'm saying that the pm stood up and said
what he said yesterday and i was in the
chamber and i think it's fair to say we
need to wait for the investigations to
be completed the government will be
publishing the full findings of the
report but you know police have a
separate independent investigation and
it's their choice to decide what to do
what i do hope is that uh you know by
completing their investigations we'll be
able to you know get clarity exactly on
what happened and
you know the decisions that will still
need to be made and we are still making
in running this country whether it's
about decisions on vaccines whether it's
about the change uh into plan a and
where we go beyond including you know
things that are operating in terms of
trying to generate jobs so that's what
we keep focused on right now while other
people complete their investigation
looking for the clarity so say all of us
it's good to see you as always thank you
very much indeed thank you minister
thank you